أجنبي
[موسيقى]
أجنبي ربما قرأت وسمعت عن
خطافات المستندات ، هل سمع أي شخص
عن الوثيقة التي تأمل طائرات الهليكوبتر التي تحلق
فوق Mar-A-Lago
جيدًا أنها قدمت لنا حوالي خمسة مليارات
دولار من الدعاية المجانية
سأقول للناس  قال إنه منزل جميل
إذا لم يكن لطيفًا جدًا ، فمن المحتمل أنهم
لن يفعلوا ذلك لأنك تعلم أنه
يحصل على تقييمات عندما ينظرون أنهم قالوا
إنه مكان جميل
اقتحموه واقتحموا منزلي
الجميع يعلم أننا لم نفعل شيئًا خاطئًا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
قبل ظهور الطاعون من
الصين ، كانت الأرقام أرقامًا
لم يصدقها أحد حتى أنني أتذكر
استطلاعات الرأي الشهيرة جدًا ،
جون ماكلولين ، جاء إلى مكتبي
قبل بدء المسرحية وقال  سيدي ،
إذا كان جورج واشنطن وأبراهام
لينكولن قد عادا على قيد الحياة من الأموات
وشكلوا فريقًا لنائب الرئيس ،
فستضربهم بنسبة 40 بالمائة ،
وهذا هو مدى جودة أرقامنا
[موسيقى]